for now the integration questions in
some senses
all you need to be able to recognize is
this
that the little sign inverse is come on
x1 you just did this this morning
one over
okay this doesn't look like what i
derived earlier this morning
let's try that again one over there
much better okay now
coz inverse obviously is almost the same
what's the difference
it's just negative tan inverse though
does
is different in two ways namely no
square root and
it's a plus so you've got this
right now i think that's all we need to
try and proceed and do questions like
this
okay now integration by parts which
we've been looking at
is not quite where this is what we
established not quite the reverse
product tool
because you can use it on things that
are products
right so just let's quickly rehearse
what is
integration by parts what does it start
with u
dv right equals
uv minus integral of v
d u okay so you can start to you get
used to it
i find that by the time i've written
this this is an easy bit and this is
just the other bit
that's how i think about it anyway
i now need to select some appropriate
functions to be u
dv etc okay so i'm going to draw a box
i'm going to have my privileges on this
side and my derivatives on this side so
i need
u and i need a dv on dx
right now just like with log x this is
not a product
but we can make it a product
right so if we consider one of the
functions as
one what should we do here
now remember it makes a difference which
one you pick
doesn't it okay so what you want to do
is pick a function that
here when you differentiate it's
workable
and here when you integrate it this
product here will be workable
right now that locks you in quite
quickly doesn't it okay
because obviously you can't put sign
inverse here because then you'll say oh
so to go to this box i'll have to
integrate it oh right that's the
question okay
so therefore you're starting to get a
sense of which ones you pick
obviously over here i'm going to put
the other function one okay so that
means sine inverse
is here and we can fill in the rest of
it can't we okay
du on dx this is this result which we've
just shown
and that would make v x
that's good okay right
let's crack this thing out of the box u
times v
just on the left-hand column i'm gonna
go downwards
that's gonna be x sine inverse x
okay then v
d u that's this by this can you see how
it's going to work
can you see it it doesn't look very nice
but the integral of
x on the square root of one minus x
squared
okay what's this thing going to be
what's this going to be what kind of
pattern does it fit
is it is it f dash on f yes
is it f dash on f well well that would
make
this this denominator f that's 1 minus x
squared to the power of
a half right so what would be the
derivative of 1 minus x squared to the
power of a half
well i guess the power would become
negative a half and then you're going to
do chain rule
that doesn't look like f dash to me but
it's close
right how am i going to use this what is
this thing
maybe if i write it out a little
differently it will help let's um have x
sine inverse here okay here i'm going to
write this as
how shall i do this let's do it like
this
if i have the integral of negative 2x
so i have made that a plus so i should
make that a half
is that okay i've changed the sign i've
changed the number
then i've got this one minus x squared
to what power
negative so this is not
f dash on f what is it
it's just it's just a function raised to
a power isn't it this is just reverse
chain rule
for you know that negative half it could
be like negative three or
five or whatever okay now if you're
struggling a little bit at this point
right you're like nah too big for my
brain going too fast okay
that's a sign for you that you need to
do the full substitution that reverse
chamber requires right
you would say something like let u
equals
now you probably shouldn't pick you
should you because we've got u's already
so maybe you make it w okay
what would you choose what would be an
appropriate choice
1 minus x squared would do it right
then you've got w you've got dw on dx
which is that
negative 2x that you've got there right
should we just proceed with this now
that we've made this substitution that
way we know get it right
what's going to happen here i've got
this a half out the front
negative 2x will become
uh what's it going to become just dw
right once i get rid of these two
together
yes so that's going to be dw and then
one minus x squared is just
w the power of minus a half oh i think
we can do that
i think we can do that okay and of
course i have my x
factors sorry my x terms
out the front there twice
when you integrate w to the power of
minus half what do you get
x sign inverse
what happens you raise the power don't
you
by one which becomes w to the power of a
half and then you
you divide by the new power don't you
which is a half
which means that is that right yeah good
and i've integrated so i better stick my
constant in
okay all right what was w again it was
that so
x sine inverse plus the square root of
cool and of course you could check it by
differentiating if you like but i'll
just tell you in advance
that's correct okay so i know you but i
just feel like
it's integration by parts it's kind of
like magic it takes something which
you're like
how do i even where do i even begin i
don't know stuff about this
well the answer is you do if you know
how to differentiate it you know a
tremendous amount
if you rearrange it the right way okay